this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this is Startalk in
the karela verse we are all social
distancing I think I don't think I catch
anything from Chuck where he is now
Chuck
I wouldn't be so sure Neil I don't know
man wouldn't it be funny if like we
leaned over and you can see us thanks
for joining us
always glad to be here guys you know we
we only pull you in when we need the big
guns in this case is this I'm gonna
spend 20 minutes talking about quantum
entanglement about it but you can speak
with great authority on this subject
given your expertise as a cosmologists
so what can you tell us about quantum
entanglement
well quantum entanglement is incredibly
fascinating I liken it to the chicken
bone game today you and I chuck we're
like at you know Thanksgiving dinner or
whatever we break a chicken bone but we
don't look at our pieces one has the big
piece one has a small piece you made a
wishbone yeah yeah
yes all right turkey bone not a chicken
bone okay yeah we just found out that
Jannah is an activated Russian spy
plant-based Thanksgiving they don't have
the actual bone so the wishing bone
experiment it's the wishing okay so we
break the wish the wishbone in half we
don't look at our pieces one has a big
piece one it's a small piece I go to
Andromeda I look at mine and I find out
I have the big piece I instantly know
you have the small piece now there's
nothing surprising about that because it
was established at the table which one
had the big piece in which one had the
small piece right now quantum
entanglement says is much weirder it
says we break the wishing bone and it's
at simultaneously in a state where I
have the small piece you have the big
and I have the big piece you have the
small piece it has not yet been
determined no it is completely in a what
we call a superposition but it has to
match we can't both have the small piece
and we can't both have the big piece or
not we both have the big piece its I big
you little you may hum little right
exactly but if they have to match
because they have to fit together to
make the original wishing bone right but
it's not actually determined who has the
big piece yet and mechanics allows yes
no is there some higher dimension is
there God who would know well if you're
real adherent to quantum mechanics you
would say that you just proven the
possibility of omniscience being because
no it is it is not established in some
sense when we in our conventional
thinking are accustomed to see thinking
certain things are real what's real is
the piece of the chicken bone is real
we're sure of it
but it's not in some sense real what's
real is the probability that's real and
that's determined and that is absolutely
deterministic and can be predicted the
probability but the existence of the
pieces of bone themselves are not yet
actualized they don't actually have a
concrete existence so you're saying you
and I are entangled with each other
right and we have to right we have to be
entangled because we can't both have the
small piece because that's not cool
so we have to be entangled in such a way
that we make we fit together correctly
to make the original wishing bone so I
can add the small piece you could have
the big piece I could have the big piece
you can have a small piece but we don't
know which one it is yet it's not just
that we don't know it's that it doesn't
actually assume a precise state yet okay
so when when does it assume that precise
state because at some point if this
can't just be potential at some point
there has to be a real
they so full of who has what piece so
yeah when does that happen and how do we
determine that and how do we observe
that so superpositions are very delicate
so when they do it as you were saying
neo like in the laboratory everyone's
trying to do this in love and it's it's
very very very delicate you have to have
systems that are not disrupted or
disturbed in any way so there was this
sort of mystique that once I I went to
Andromeda and I looked at it that the
act of my conscious looking forced it to
assume a certain state and that's not
really quite right what happened was
just all the molecules in my body and
the air that I'm breathing in the room
all of these things destroy the delicate
superposition they they not get about it
imagine you know a pencil standing on
its end so yeah if you go and clumsily
look at it you knock it over but it
doesn't have to do with your
consciousness it's just the interaction
of all the particles and all the
molecules and all those things that make
it impossible for it to maintain this
delicate state of standing on its point
okay so now so now the state becomes
actualized in front of you
yes I look and I know for sure I've got
the big piece i won but what happened is
I somehow seemingly forced faster than
the speed of light from Andromeda to the
earth instantaneously forced your your
state to also assume a precise state
because you can't know that
without me also knowing my state right
well can I can look at it and know it
and I instantaneously know you have the
smaller piece of bone and that's that
but you don't know whether I had looked
at yet or not that's right so but that's
but that's only because the the to kid
that there has to be that balance of
business right
that's not raising its due right they
have to fit together to make the
regeneration bone exactly it can't be
that I look at mine and then you also
look at yours and we both have a big
piece of wishing huh
I so the big the big question here is
can you encrypt messages this way so
that no one can jump in between and and
and capture your secret code that you're
trying to communicate from Andromeda to
earth yes so funnily enough I cannot
communicate to you faster than the speed
of light that I know I have the bigger
piece information was communicated
nonetheless it what so you look at your
piece and instantaneously you see the
small shard but you don't know that I
that you didn't do it you don't know
that it was you who collapse waste
function and so for me to tell you I
just used fancy language sorry claps
wave function meaning forced it to
assume a specific state for me to tell
you I would still have to send you a
mail in the post I don't know I don't
need you to send me a signal because I
know this isn't that communication
faster than light
it is communication faster than light
but neither of us know who was the one
who did it
exactly because it's really it's not
communication faster than light it's
knowledge faster than light I don't have
the knowing I can't believe West or the
night but I can definitely force that
wishing bone to assume a specific state
faster than the speed of light and you
could learn about it later like I could
tell you it was this time in Andromeda
when I looked at the bone I can send you
a intergalactic mail in the post and
you'll get it and you'll say oh yeah
it's true when Jana looked at the bone I
looked at mine a second later I'm
thinking about cryptologist so can you
sit can I send can we entangle a
sequence of bits oh you will right and
then you choose bits in a certain way
that then collapse my wave function back
here and I say Oh Jana has the secret
rocket formula and it's this in
principle yes I can throw you that
information faster than the speed of
light it would be hard to control which
information I send to you because I
can't know if I'm gonna look at my which
piece it's gonna be okay
but let's say you looking at 1 7 9 and
yeah the 12 particles that we entangled
yeah hey and that's a decision you make
and I will know and I look up in a code
and I say forget that it's big chicken
little chicken all right
I look at a code and say if she does
whatever 9 that means she's safe in
Normandy with the rocket formula yeah it
you sort of can do it the problem is
when you we can when you look at your at
your piece you don't know if you're the
one who forced it to assume earth
position or if I was there's probably
some clever way around it but let's say
you so it's not as though it's not a so
you can look at your particle and wait
to see it right that's a yes because
then you could do exactly what you're
saying right you decrypt a message I do
for seven to nine and you look at your
book and that means you know I'm safe on
the shores but but once you're looking
at the thing it's not like you can watch
it come out of entanglement into the
state by looking at it you no longer
know if you are the one who forced it
where I was Wow Wow yeah so yeah it's
not a good way to break up with somebody
is what's it's not me it's you I mean
it's not you it's me
I don't know what's the message just
looked at Wow
so just relating to quantum computing at
all it's just about to say absolutely so
quantum computing uses entanglement and
you know in in a very delicate way and
the arguments are that the computational
power of apart
incredibly faster than a classical
computer and there's a lot of progress
made on quantum computing not all of
which I understand a lot of it's some
pretty wild stuff and it's very funny
it's changing every day
what if it's exploiting quantum
entanglement as one of the quantum
absolutely elements that or meaning yes
yes yes so now can you tell me the
difference between the entanglement and
tunneling or are they the same
well it's interesting question they're
both quantum mechanical phenomena yeah
and they're related but they're not
exactly the same so quantum entanglement
talks about you know one thing that
splits and had to assume complimentary
state so that could go back together
again in the right combination but I
could have a single particle inside a
box and because that particle is no more
real than the pieces of the wishing bone
it has some probability of being on the
other side just outside the box outside
the wall on the other side of all
there's just some chances it's there you
have to stop thinking of it as a
billiard ball that actually exists all
the time and is there you have to start
thinking of it as something that has a
probability of being somewhere has a
probability of moving so what you're
saying is the parking is a convenient
way to start thinking about it but the
particle actually exists in a space not
only in the box but outside the book
with the probability that's not I'm
gonna tell you what I just heard from a
non astrophysics you know you just told
me that nothing is real no no seriously
you just you just basically said
nothing's real like test
I mean seriously that's yeah that's oh
God so so here's an example also so
tiring tunneling is the idea that
there's some probability it's gonna end
up outside the box there is some
probability that I
just pass through the wall unharmed it's
very very very very small but so here's
one we're thinking about it like there's
atoms where you have the nucleus and
then you have these regions where an
electron can occupy and one electron can
occupy like a lobe here and a lobe here
and it never never never goes between
never but it's still one electron and
the probability of finding it here is
some probability and the probability
here is some probability and you do the
experiment over and over again and
sometimes you like transparent sometimes
it's there it does not make its way over
in the ordinary billiard ball sense and
janna correct me if I'm not saying this
right these quantum forces and
phenomenon are particularly manifest at
matter on its smallest scales but as you
start collecting matter together
macroscopically these effects and that I
don't know canceling is not the right
world word they end up being the
probabilities go way down they go way
down so what would happen is Chuck for
you to end up on the other side of the
wall all of your atoms would have to
sort of have manifest that probability
simultaneously and that's that that is
an astronomically low likelihood it
might did I do
right Jenna absolutely and and also like
things like quantum entanglement are
again very very delicate and so when I
shine a light on it and I've embarked it
with photons or I'd like try to look at
it or grab it or I do whatever I need to
do to make the observation
it's not about my mind my consciousness
it's simply about the interaction of my
apparatus and that thing and it then I
and I just break it to some extent I
break so then how can you ever see it if
you can't put light on it to see it how
do you ever see it it's a really
interesting question it's really a
probabilistic experiment you do it over
and over again and you measure the
probabilities and it's different than
the probabilities that we would have if
it was the classical experiment at the
dinner
table where we broke the wishing bone
it's right actually measure with large
numbers that it's a different it
conforms to quantum mechanics and not to
the dinner table experiment Wow Chuck
has just lost a week of sleep right I
got all right we gotta lay on this plane
so yo Janna as always thanks for being a
friend of Startalk I love being here and
it's great I'm hoping yeah I'm hoping
we'll all be together in person soon
enough miss you guys are talking first
Chuck always good to have you
definitely this is Neil deGrasse Tyson
as always serving as your personal
astrophysicist and bidding you to keep
looking up
you